[Applause]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to a lot
of movies try hard to shock us nowadays
with trigger words disturbing imagery
gross ideas but many of them come out as
exactly that just trigger words
disturbing imagery and gross ideas what
makes something truly shocking is the
meaning behind it a little kid can say a
lot of bad things but the message
fueling it is what declares if it's
worth the effort to pay attention to so
what I told you in our PC media there is
a smart funny film that said giant
corporations are good manipulating the
masses should be treasured haggling with
cancer patients is an art public figures
pushing good health shouldn't be trusted
body counts can lead to long friendships
and of course smoking is fuckin cool you
would say how the hell did that get a
why for a reason why the fuck aren't I
talking about it well that movie is a
little comic masterpiece called thank
you for smoking jason reitman 'he's
first film that focuses on characters
and values that you do more likely see
as the villains in a bad after-school
special our star is Nick Naylor played
by Aaron Eckhart a lobbyist and
spokesperson for the tobacco industry
whose job is to convince as many people
as possible that smoking is not only
good for you it's great for you and the
funny thing is he's actually kind of
good at it it's not only our hope it's
in our best interest to keep Robin alive
and smoking Iran goodies of this world
want the Robin williger's to die so that
their budgets will go up this is nothing
less than trafficking in human misery
and you sir ought to be ashamed of
yourself his archrival as a senator from
Vermont way by way mhm Macey who's
trying to prove what should be very easy
that smoking is bad for you but as we
see the senator is just as manipulative
as the tobacco companies just on the
other side when you're looking for a
cancer kid you should be hopeless you
should have a wheelchair a little pet
goldfish he carries around in a ziplock
bag hopeless how often do you see a
senator promoting healthy living as the
villain in anything he meets every week
with two other spokespeople for
corporations that claimed a lot of lives
to compare and contrast who's doing the
most damage they playfully call
themselves the merchants of death why he
even meets with media experts to spread
more and more the message that smoking
is great and even tries to encourage
children to pick it up
team smoking our bread and butter is
falling like a ship from heaven we sell
cigarettes and they're cool available
and addictive the job is almost done for
us too the film's credit it makes no
qualms that's doing very dirty things
but what makes it so interesting is that
makes us root for what many would
consider the bad guy just because of how
incredibly likable he is Nick Naylor is
charming smart once what he does is
glitter what he does but most
importantly and even surprisingly has a
moral Center especially when it comes to
raising his son he wants his boy to turn
out well but raising him and smart and
ethical values is tricky given what he
does he does however explain what he
does rather well let's say that you're
defending chocolate and I'm defending
vanilla it's the best ice cream I
wouldn't order any other I believe that
we need freedom and choice when it comes
to our ice cream and that joy Naylor
that is the definition of Liberty but
you didn't prove that vanilla was the
best I don't have to I think that you're
wrong and if you're wrong I'm right as
you'd expect this creates conflict and
asking himself what is truly right or
wrong and nowhere is that more prevalent
than in the film's climax he has to go
up against the senator after his lowest
moment and prove that what he's doing is
ethical sound and wise and all while his
kid is watching the interesting thing
though is where most movies would take
the path of having him realize he's evil
and turn his life around he instead
makes a different decision but
nevertheless just as important to stop
being morally vague and stand firm
focused and detailed about his beliefs
it's called education it doesn't come
off the side of a cigarette carton it
comes from our teachers and more
importantly our
it is the job of every parent to warn
their children of all the dangers of the
world including cigarettes so that one
day when they get older they can choose
for themselves and yes that belief is
saying that smoking is okay on his 18th
birthday will you share a cigarette with
him you seem to have a lot to say about
how we should raise our children what
have your own if he really wants to
cigarette I'll buy him his first pack
really think about that the happy ending
is our main character teaching his child
that if he wants to smoke he should be
allowed to try to think of any other
movie nowadays that could not only do
that but do that in a smart intelligent
way in fact he does it with an argument
that's practically ahead of its time
he brings up how Vermont a big promoter
of cheese is a bigger killer than
cigarettes because of cholesterol and
that the promotion of the product has
done much more damage than the tobacco
companies ever could leaving of course
still one of the film's funniest lines
the great state of Vermont will not
apologize for its cheese this is an
issue nowadays that's getting more and
more attention there's new specials
movies books and yes even lobbyists
trying to prove that a lot of our food
is poison whether this is a good thing
or a bad thing is up for debate and yeah
I guess it is being debated but it does
come down to what that issue and this
film are all about choice the film isn't
really about smoking it's about
validating the rhetoric and allowing you
to do what you want to do with your body
don't believe me what's the film again
and answer me this question how many
people do you see smoke nobody there is
not a single shot of anybody puffing
anything in the entire movie they talk
about it endlessly from beginning to end
but not once does anyone ever take a
puff of a cigarette because that's not
what the film is about smoking is used
as a symbol for the hazards we're going
to subject ourselves to but nevertheless
have the right to subject' ourselves to
it
the smoking is very similar to our main
character we know he's bad for us and
we'd probably be healthier if we didn't
allow him into our lives but there is
value to his existence we can admire
that he doesn't force anyone to join his
side he
vince's them which is a trait we'd all
love to acquire and not only does he do
it well he does it with passion he loves
what he does he loves how not only can
he do it legally but as creatively as
possible in fact the alternate ending
almost ruins the entire film by going
against everything that it's been
standing for stabbing in the back all
the controversial truths that make it so
shockingly unique thank God they went
with the original and better ending a
conclusion that Nick sees as a victory
for him but the senator sees as a
failure for him two totally different
viewpoints yet the exact same outcome
again it's the choice of the audience to
decide whether this was an ethical move
or not and the great thing is the whole
entire movies like that you could see
this film as a story about a terrible
world like 1984 righteous rebels like V
for Vendetta or so we're in between like
Fight Club but the difference between
those movies that were so shocking in
their day and thank you for smoking is
those stories always centered around a
corrupt and controlled environment that
people fought against with this it's
embracing the corrupt and controlled
environment and actually seeing the
advantages of it that seems a million
times more shocking than any of these
other films it has a point of view that
is almost never seen at least not in
such a major mass market it's a message
that's manipulative diabolical and most
shockingly you find kind of agreeing
with part of it how much is intentional
satire and ethical truth is up to the
viewer but in most shocking films it's
pretty easy to tell who you're supposed
to root for and who you're not this film
leaves it totally up to the viewer it's
kind of like Patton some people can
watch the film and love it and other
people can watch the film and hate them
but neither one is incorrect it's just
different point of views of hard truths
thank you for smoking walks that line
but still has the balls to stamp
unpopular opinions that'll get anyone
who sees it talking so why aren't more
people talking about it maybe because
it's shock tactics are different than
most other shock tactics in film it
didn't have the gore sex or trigger
words that get most controversial movies
the huge amount of attention they
usually get
don't get me wrong it didn't bomb or
anything but if this came out today
chances are it would probably get a few
more people upset however for those that
were fortunate enough to discover this
little gem it opens up a world of
controversy then that only becomes
interesting to talk about but
surprisingly fun to talk about how many
other films make it enjoyable to talk
about something that's uncomfortable
it's enjoyably uncomfortable a beautiful
oxymoron it's a brilliant comedy that
needs to be talked about shunned loved
and hated more than it is put simply it
represents everything in America that's
wonderful and terrible both at the same
time and speaking of shocking violence
and gore isn't there a certain something
that's coming up next month
[Music]
[Applause]
hello everybody Doug Walker here doing
the charity shout out and this is one
that has definitely been talked about it
in the past and has gotten a lot of
promotion but deserves even more it's
called donorschoose.org and this is a
wonderful charity that donates money to
schools that need all sorts of things
they need books they need computers they
need money for everything education
related and as everybody knows I mean
education is so important every child
deserves as much education as possible
in the same amount of education and so
many of them aren't getting it and they
just need to go to a place where they
feel they can learn and they won't be
afraid of the place and it can feel
comforting and it can feel warm and it
can feel wonderful and that's what this
charity does and the wonderful thing I
mean the absolutely fantastic thing
about it is that you know exactly where
the money is going because you choose
where it's going you say exactly to what
project or what what event you want the
money to go to you literally search all
of these listings saying we need money
for books we need money for computers
whatever and you can donate whatever
amount that you want so that's one of
the great things about it
this has gotten a lot of attention from
celebrities like Stephen Colbert and
Oprah Winfrey and there's so many people
that just praise the heck out of it
we've done charity auctions for them
before it is definitely a good place to
put your money because you know exactly
where it's going and you know it's going
to a good cause so definitely if you get
a chance go check it out education is so
important you know we are giving our
world to these kids and they are gonna
grow up and they are gonna be the
leaders so the more they can learn the
more intelligent they can be and the
more they have opportunity to that
education the better world we're gonna
create so please definitely go and check
it out
you
[Music]